candid
truth what up everybody thank you for
joining us at candid truth we're going
to talk about the truth and we're going
to get candid with it I'm here tonight
in Colorado wanted to do a video so it's
a different set you see going on might
be a little echoey I don't know this is
something that a lot of people ask like
does it matter which Bible version I use
and for a long time I didn't think it
did to me it just seemed like well some
of these other translations they're just
saying the same thing but they're using
in kind of Modern English so it's more
easier to understand and the first Bible
that I actually started reading was the
New Living Translation now at the time I
thought it was a translation it was
given to me it's actually called New
Living Translation but it is a
paraphrase ironically enough and so I
remember there was a couple things as I
as I began to study God's word and began
to seek truth deeper I started to see
that there were some things were
different in the different translations
that actually were big deals so
sometimes it might not be a big deal
like if it says snake instead of serpent
or wine skin or bottle or something you
know like some of those things are just
nuances it doesn't really matter they
mean the same
thing um contextually but it's just a
different word I I don't care about that
now there are some people that get a
little extreme and they're like King
James only
the King James is the Living Word and
it's the only untainted the only true
translation I don't go that far now I
will
admit the King James version is my go-to
like and it and it it's because it
happened three different times I was
searching God show me the truth I want
to know the truth and three different to
me Supernatural ways like signs were
given to me that I should go back to to
the King James Bible uh I can't remember
all the different ones but I will tell
you one
specifically was a a very a very U
prominent word got changed to a very
vague word and I'll go into that but uh
let's just go ahead and get into this so
I'm going to put a link in the
description to this free resource that
you can get it's a book called in in awe
of Thy
word I own this book it's super thick
it's really indepth it's really way too
academic for me like the book is is huge
but maybe somebody's out there who loves
to read this is uh I think Chick
Publications yeah it's on uh Chick
Publications website but in the first
beginning of it it's really cool how
it'll show you just how serious these
translations the differences in them are
so I want to show you that stuff because
it really it really can have a huge
difference one word you can change one
word in a sentence and completely change
the meaning right so check this out I
want to show you guys
something so in the King James Version
Psalms 104 and 5 it says Wicked his ways
are always Grievous now the word
Grievous means it's a negative it's it's
bad right it means
you're grieving it's a negative
connotation but in the NIV it says
Wicked his ways are always
prosperous wow now that's a huge change
we're not talking about changing the
word Grievous to sorrowful or something
like that we're talking about changing
the word Grievous to prosperous the new
King James version now this one is I
going to step on some toes because I
know a lot of people that use a new King
James I have a new King James Bible that
I use often but right here new King
James says Wicked his ways are always
prospering that is a huge
difference ESV Wicked his ways Prosper
at all times I'm not sure what the
hcsb is but it says Wicked his ways are
always
secure what now these are huge
changes these are not simply changing
the word thee and thou and all that kind
of stuff now this book actually gets
into why the King James uses the words
thee and thou now I might Slaughter this
a little bit butcher it but there
are very uh distinct things like so the
might be like you and thou might be like
everyone or something like that so maybe
you know we use the English language and
we'll say Hey you come here and we're
talking about a single person or we
could say
you uh I welcome you all right and it's
like you is still the same word but I'm
talking to a crowd of people thee and
thou and all that is the same kind of
thing like it differentiates whether
it's talking about you in general or you
specifically and so this book is really
interesting if you are academic like
that uh Ecclesiastes 8:10 in the King
James says Wicked were forgotten NIV
says Wicked receive praise wied receive
praise like this is totally
anti-biblical this is Blasphemous ESV
English Standard Version Wicked were
praised Isaiah 9:3 says in the King
James it says not increased the
joy now you can simply just remove one
word like not totally changes everything
the NIV and the T NIV have removed the
word not the new King James version now
most people think that the new king King
James version is simply a slightly
modernized version of the King James and
so a lot of people use it but look at
this
change not increased its Joy or
increased its Joy huge difference just
from the King James to the new King
James ESV English Standard Version got
rid of the word not nasv got rid of the
word not Colossians 21:18 and the King
James things which he hath not seen in
the ni V the tnv the
nsab got rid of the word not so now it
says what he has seen Visions he has
seen totally changes it so does the
Bible translation matter yes I get this
question a lot do what Bible version
should I use and I don't want to sound
like some stickler and be like you have
to use King James I don't want to sound
like that but at the same time I feel
like that because like I said three
Supernatural kind of acts brought me
back to the King James version I said
after the third time I said I'm never
using any other version and so what I
mean by I'm not like a some kind of
extremist is some people will say that
if I was given a presentation and I used
another translation that said the same
thing but in an easier to understand
wording they would say that's
blasphemous you can't even use new King
James or English Standard even if the
context means the same thing I don't
believe that I believe hey if I'm just
saying hey the Bible does say something
about you know for God so loved the
world he gave his son to die for the
world I believe you can paraphrase as
long as you are keeping the context the
same this is out of context this is
completely changing the context into
something that's completely Blasphemous
and
sacriligious um so I'm not to the
extreme where I'm saying you can't ever
use another trans ation I actually like
to parallel I like to use Bible Hub and
look at what other Bible translations
say because sometimes it does I'll be
honest sometimes the the other
translations actually make more sense
than the King James and that happened
when I was doing the alcohol
presentation you know one of the verses
said by you know use the tithe money to
buy wine and strong drink but other
translations said by wine which is grape
juice or juice in general or similar
drink now to me similar drink made a lot
more sense than strong drink because the
Bible would never say that alcohol is a
sin being drunk is a sin but spend the
tithe money on some alcohol it wouldn't
say that so sometimes there are times
when other translations even make more
sense Hosea 101 says in the King James
Israel is an empty Vine but the nasv
says is a luxuriant vine ESV says
luxuriant Vine NIV says a spreading Vine
meaning to grow the opposite of
empty Isaiah 9:1 and the King James says
afterward did more grievously affect
Galilee but in the nasb it says later on
he shall make it glorious Galilee NIV in
the future he will honor Galilee oh my
goodness SV in the latter times he has
made glorious Galilee the complete
opposite Proverbs 26:22 says in the KJV
the words of the tail Bearer are as
wounds but the NIV says the words of
Gossip are like Choice morsels what the
words of a gossip are like Choice
morsels nasb says the words of a
Whisperer are like dainty morsels come
on this is Blasphemous
ESV the words of a whisper are like
delicious morsels
hcsb a gossips words are like Choice
food wow Isaiah 18:2 in the KJV says a
nation scattered and peeled a nation
meded
out and trotten down but the NIV says a
people tall and smooth skin and
aggressive nation of strange speech like
this doesn't even this is completely
different context completely and it says
the new King James is similar gives a
similar kind of Thing 1 Peter 3:3 in the
King James says let it not be an outward
adorning but the nasb says let not your
adornment be merely external now that
is very subtle remember Satan is not
just an outright liar I mean he he is in
a sense but he is a deceiver more than
anything because deception actually
deceives people you can't deceive people
with an out outright lie you can't hand
somebody a bottle of bleach and say oh
it's water go ahead and drink up you
would never do that but you serve
somebody a glass of ice cold lemonade
with a straw and an umbrella and you put
a couple drops of poison in there and
somebody drink it right up right it's
that 1% error that can make everything
go off track 99% truth is not truth and
so right here when you say you know let
not your adornment be merely external is
is actually justifying to have a an
external adorning don't let it just be
the outward also have it inward but it's
completely opposite of what the King
James says where it says don't let your
adorning be out outward New King James
Version New King James versus the King
James do not let your adornment be
merely out
outward so here we have in 1 Corinthians
11:16 in the KJV it says we have no such
custom now this is super subtle we have
no such custom hcsb says we have no
other custom so other or such very
subtle but does change the context NIV
tnv nasb all say the same
thing um when God blesses new versions
sometimes curse uh Hosea 11:12 in the
KJV says Judah yet ruleth with God NIV
says Judah is unruly against God nasb
Judah is also unruly against god wow
Genesis 273 9-40 and the King James says
thy dwelling shall be the fatness of the
earth NIV says your dwelling will be
away from the Earth's Rich richness
completely different context nasb away
from for the fertility of the Earth
shall be your dwelling ESV says away
from the fatness of the Earth shall be
your dwelling now if someone tells you
if God tells you your dwelling is going
to be in the fatness of the
earth that's totally different than
saying away from the fatness of earth
right see
that Psalm 299 says in the King James
the voice of the Lord maketh the Hinds
to
calav I'll be honest I don't even know
what that means NIV says the voice of
the Lord twists The
Oaks I don't even know if that's
comparable because I honestly don't even
know what that means I'm just being
honest here Galatians 2:20 in the King
James says I live
NIV says I no longer live t NIV says I
no longer live
tcsb I no longer live Proverbs 18:24 and
the King James version says a man that
hath friends must show himself friendly
but in the nasb it says a man of many
friends comes to
ruin what a man of many friends comes to
ruin that's not even comparable NIV a
man of many companions make come to ruin
a man of many companions may come to
ruin a man with many friends may be
harmed look at these translations this
is insane and there's so many of them
Colossians 4:8 says in the King James he
might know your estate but in the ESV it
says you may know how we
are see that see how different this is
in Jeremiah 513 in the King James it
says let the Archer Bend his bow but the
ESV says let not the Archer Bend his bow
just adding that one word not same thing
in the NIV
nasb uh job 16:20 and the KJV says my
friend scorn me in the NIV it says my
intercessor is my
friend wait a minute my intercessor is
my friend my friends scorn me this is so
confusing right and that's what's going
to happen in the last days Satan is
deceiving the whole world don't you
think that it's Satan
primary attack to attack the church to
attack Christians he doesn't care about
the world he doesn't have to win the
world they're already deceived they're
already living for the lustful desires
of their flesh they're alcoholics
they're watching every Wicked thing that
the world is putting out there listening
to all the Wicked Music he does not have
to spend his efforts and time on them
they are already deceived where is Satan
spending his efforts getting in the
church dividing the church on these
topics on these issues changing the word
of God saying hey I got you a new
version this one's better it's easier to
understand and I've added a couple words
and I've removed a couple words but
don't worry about that it's easier to
understand and you'll enjoy it a lot
more but you're getting the completely
wrong idea when you read it Satan is a
dragon deceiving the entire world and we
have to be vigilant we have to have
discernment I'm so thankful for
resources like this that are out there
um Proverbs 25:23 and the King James
says the north The North Wind driveth
away rain but the NIV says as a North
Wind brings rain nasb ESV hcsb all say
bring rain and produces rain complete
opposite of what the King James says
Matthew 11:12 says the Kingdom of Heaven
suffereth violence
and the violent take it by force now the
NIV says the Kingdom of Heaven has been
forcefully
advancing and forceful men lay hold of
it wait a minute the Kingdom of Heaven
suffereth violence that means we the
Believers we are being
persecuted and the violent take it by
force we're not violent we're told to
turn the other cheek right we're the
opposite of violent it's saying the
violent take it by force but this says
the Kingdom of Heaven has been
forcefully advancing and forceful men
lay hold of it wow completely
different and so that's the end of these
examples there's a lot more in this book
but I wanted to show you another verse
because in Matthew
17:21 in the King James
the verse says how be it so the
disciples were trying to cast out a
demon out of this person and they came
to Jesus they're like why can't we cast
The Demon out and Jesus responded and he
said how be it this kind goeth not out
but by prayer and fasting so there's
power in fasting there's power in prayer
but there's also power in prayer in
numbers right where two or more are
gathered in agreement that thing will
come to pass you have to have belief
you have to have prayer you have to have
agreement with two or more in agreement
and then there's fasting so there's
different like levels of prayer that
bring more power and Jesus said this
type of demon comes out by nothing but
by prayer and
fasting King James version says the same
thing look at The New American Standard
Bible it's not there the verse is
completely missing nasb it says
it um some of these say it but look
American Standard Version not there it
doesn't exist the Bible verse is
literally skipped it goes from Matthew
17:20 to Matthew
17:22 the verse is omitted why because
Satan knows there's power in fasting he
doesn't want the Christian to know the
power of fasting in prayer right if if
if fasting can cast out demons don't you
think that that's a verse that Satan's
going to want to remove of course yeah
and it's been happening English revised
vers version it's not in there now
there's actually some versions I don't
see them listed in here but there's some
versions that actually just omit the
word fasting so it just says this type
of demon comes out by only by prayer
what do you think the disciples were
doing of course they were praying that's
what they were doing but they weren't
they didn't have the
fasting and so Jesus taught them about
that and Satan has removed it now I want
to show
you uh the Bible verse that I was saying
that there was some Supernatural things
that happened that made me go back to
the King James version to me this is a
big deal some people they might try to
act like it's not a big deal but it is
so when I was studying about the Sabbath
I was I was going verse by verse with
somebody and he was saying okay turn to
this verse and I was looking wow that's
clear yeah the Sabbath seventh day it
makes sense it's the fourth Commandment
it keeps reiterating it over and over
Jesus kept it as deciples kept it and
then he showed me this verse and I was
reading in the New Living Translation
remember it says all Humanity will come
to worship me from week to week and from
month to month when I read that my
friend said is that was your says I said
yeah he said look at mine he showed me
in the King James because because look
at this so I was reading from week to
week from month to month he said read
mine and the King James and it shall
come to pass that from one new moon to
another and from one Sabbath to another
shall All Flesh come to worship before
me now the context of this verse is
saying that Sabbath is never going away
Sabbath is going to be kept in eternity
because the verse right before it says
for as the new heavens and the new Earth
that I shall make shall remain before
thee it says in 22 it says for as the
new heavens and the new Earth which I
will make shall remain before me sayith
the Lord so shall your seed and your
name remain so he's talking about the
new heavens and the new Earth and the
very next verse says and it shall come
to pass that from one new moon to
another from one Sabbath to another
shall All Flesh come to worship before
me sayeth the Lord now to me that is
important just as Satan would remove the
word fasting right because fasting cast
out demons and we know that in the last
days those who overcome the mark of the
beast those who have right to the Tree
of Life are those who keep the
Commandments of God if you look in
Revelation just look up Commandments and
look up Revelation you'll see it three
times you'll see blessed are they who
keep the Commandments of God and have
the faith and testimony of Jesus Christ
that they may have right to the tree of
life and may enter into the city in into
the gates into the
city if Satan knows that his final
deception is to deceive all of humanity
into a new form of worship a worship
that's forced and seems like peace and
safety because when they say peace and
safety sudden destruction will come upon
them Satan wants to stop you from
obeying God trust and Obey there's no
other way some people think that belief
is all you need in Jesus and there's
nothing else that has to be done but
obedience is the fruit of belief if I
really trust somebody or if I'm shopping
for a car I'm going to bring my friend
who knows a lot about cars and when he
says go with this one Mikey this is the
best car for the best money it's going
to last you a long time I'm G to buy
that car because I trust my friend I'm
going to obey what he says I'm not going
to disobey right if you love me keep my
commandments so if you love him you will
not o disobey him right you will not
have other gods before him you will not
put put anything before him you won't
make it graven images you won't take his
name in vain you won't commit adultery
and lie and steal and cheat and you'll
keep the fourth Commandment and so when
Satan has changed the word Sabbath to
week from one week to another that's
huge so for me when I that was the last
straw when before it was it was two
other things there was a verse that I
was looking for I was trying to find a
verse about being being led like a sheep
to the slaughter a lamb to the slaughter
or something I was searching it couldn't
even find on Google and hours went by
and I started digging around for
something else something completely
different I was digging around in my
closet in the top shelf and I found a
little box of a Bible that my mom had
given me and I just felt convicted right
then like I need to read and so I open
it up the small Bible and I and I open
it to where the ribbon
was and as I'm reading I'm reading this
whole left
Page and right before I went to the next
page this voice which was Satan and back
then I was still drinking and smoking
weed and everything so Satan definitely
could influence me I heard do you really
believe in this Lord of the Rings
nonsense like as I was reading the Bible
I felt those words heard those words in
my mind and I almost wanted to close the
book but I fought through that I said no
I do believe these words and as I read
there it was he was led like a lamb to
the slaughter and I just started weeping
I couldn't believe it I was like I can't
believe this is exactly what I was
looking for I went in that closet
looking for something totally different
and it was a King James Bible that was
the first time that I had something like
that happen and then another time it was
something else and and then when it came
to this issue of week instead of Sabbath
I was like that's it I I'm not reading
anything but the King James like I said
I'm not one of these people that's like
King James only you can never use any
other version because they're all
tainted I don't believe that I do
believe that there are people who have
come to Christ reading other
translations there's people right now
who are in jail or whatever and they're
reading the Bible in the English
Standard Version and they're coming to
Christ I believe that but as Believers
we need to keep seeking truth we need to
keep searching for truth like it's gold
because the Bible does say that God
Winks at our sins committed in ignorance
but once the light of truth comes then
we are to repent and so this isn't
exactly a sin to read another version
but God's people are destroyed for a
lack of knowledge right we need to be
searching for truth like gold we need to
have a love of the truth that's what the
Bible says because they had not a love
of the truth they will be turned over to
a strong delusion and so in these last
days it's our responsibility to use all
these resources we have we have the
internet the world's entire library in
the palm of our hand there's no excuse
for ignorance in this time period we
live in the information age we have more
information at our fingertips one book
used to cost $1,000 doar back in the day
because scribes had to write it now
there's no excuse we need to search for
truth we need to be loving the truth and
we need to be living the truth I hope
this was a blessing to you guys guys the
link for that uh book that we were just
looking at in all of Thy word will be in
the description check it out download it
share this with your family and friends
because there might be some of your
family and friends that are reading
these other translations and they're
like getting some kind of skewed message
I hope this was a blessing if it was
please click the thumbs up it really
helps this video get into the algorithm
so that more people can see this
information and learn the truth as well
the candid truth if this is your first
time click subscribe click the
notification Bell so you won't miss
another video and we love you we thank
you we can't do this without you if you
guys want to support this ministry you
can do so by going to our website and
clicking on donate there's a lot of
different options there we actually got
some t-shirts too stuff like this be
cool use your brain we got uh some Bible
verse t-shirts but that's what we want
to do here we want to use our brain
Hollywood's out here trying to tell you
it's it's dumb to use your brain you're
a nerd if you use your brain don't you
just want to be cool and dumb and get
the chick so we're going against that
we're saying it's cool to use your brain
Satan doesn't want you to be smart he
doesn't want you to be aware of his
deceptions so we're exposing those
deceptions we're deciphering the
deceptions see you next time on can of
Truth